bon on est à garges-lès-gonesse
aujourd'hui pour le cri challenge saison
2 on va passer des vieux du quartier
vous des faits quels quartiers
tout a commencé par un défi écologique
garges les gonesse a désigné la ville de
trappes dans une vidéo dans le cadre de
ma cité va briller
une opération lancée l'année dernière
dans les quartiers de france les
trappistes ont donc décidé de se
mobiliser ce mercredi 22 juillet l'idée
c'était de collecter le plus de déchets
possible donc en moins de deux heures
nous la semaine dernière à
garges-lès-gonesse on a rassemblé à 1700
litres de déchets et à voilà donc le
gagnant c'est celui qui remporte au
total plus d'une centaine de jeunes
trappistes se sont mobilisés dans onze
quartiers de la ville s'en rendre compte
par eux-mêmes que la au lieu de jeu leur
aire de jeux et le de vie comme elle
vous commis par bomba
se détériorent avec le temps il va des
papiers qui légua range donc
donc je pense qu'ils sont tous éveillé
et qui sont prêts à nettoyer leur propre
environnement
on a là plusieurs associations qui sont
rassemblés avec les services municipaux
avec des citoyens qui ont souhaité
également s'engager et on relève
largement le défi posé par la ville de
garges et on montre que notre
environnement la propreté notre quartier
c'est notre affaire et en se mobilisant
en étant capable de faire du tri en
étant capable d'éduquer aussi nos
enfants à la préservation de la propreté
de leur environnement ont fait un pas en
avant vers notre projet qui est celui de
la ville propre
au total les trappistes ont récolté
trois mille six cents litres pendant
l'opération 2000 de plus que
garges-lès-gonesse la semaine d'avant
résultat qui leur permet de remporter la
victoire